hey what's going on it's bill burn it's
time for the Thursday afternoon just
before Friday Monday morning podcast and
ah just checking in on you what's going
on how are you how's things in your
world it's almost Friday ah today's pay
day right you're going to get that
[__] check that [__] douche is
going to come by with his gold tote
sucks right poke his head in your
cubicle where that [__] envelope down
right and he's going to be talking to
you and you're not going to hear me
that's going to be sitting there smile
or maybe it's a lady
maybe it's the web woman maybe she's
coming along with her sensible shoes you
know she doesn't have a heel on it right
she's taking it back you know tell me
what to do with my body how come guys
don't have to walk around in high heels
why do women have to ruin their feet and
their [__] lower backs you know
that's like one of those [__] stories
that like with this stupid-ass [__]
election would actually become like a
national story some dumb [__] like that
you know complete [__] clickbait
horseshit who gives a [__] you know I
don't know I don't know how people sit
down and watch these conventions my
entire life I've never been able to get
through one they are so [__]
cringe-worthy
it's so phony it's so fake the [__]
smiles those maniacal hey like just
totally in your head you know the
candidates at this point they have to be
completely [__] exhausted they don't
want to answer any more [__]
questions and they still have like
another 90 days of this [__] that they
have to go through you know you know
like when a team goes through the Super
Bowl right and you got the two weeks
right before and they just [__] sit
there all [__] reporters run out of
questions or they just sitting there
that's two weeks of that [__] and those
players they go nuts just doing that
it's [__] komova guys [__] my
Yanna sports only
this [__] calm over dude in the clan
there they they just keep answering the
same [__] question it's got to be
easier for Trump you know what I mean he
just has to just make up some [__]
listening to Trump give his speech is no
different than [__] listening to me
do this podcast he might as well just be
laying there in his [__] underwear
his [__] boxes and just talking to
the American people just whatever the
[__] he's thinking a just says it and
then like [__] you know whatever
twenty minutes later somebody corrects
them on Twitter that happens being all
the time every time I put out a podcast
somebody goes hey man not trying to be a
dick but just let you know you know yeah
but George Bush thing I thought they
were just making fun of George Bush
Danson I didn't know he was doing it at
the [__] it's um you know the police
officers funerals the memorial service
you know I thought Lewis Hamilton was
the upstart driver they're like no it's
actually Nico Rosberg just every [__]
week I do that but I'm just some
[__] I'm not actually running for
office oh you're not bill thank you for
bringing that up we didn't [__]
realize it so anyways uh that you you
truly are a [__] patriot if you could
sit through those things especially this
election because uh I can't [__] do
it I can't oh my god Rudy Giuliani guys
I gotta [__] was going off Jesus
Christ what the [__] was he what was
going on with it
I love how his voice kept going up like
he thought the crowd was going to go
with them and they didn't really they
kept clapping but he kept increasing his
energy and his passion and nothing
happened at least when Howard Dean got
going crazy went ahead when he did that
thing that he was reacting to the energy
least he was [__] connected to those
people Rudy I don't know what he was
doing yeah say the worst [__] image
you could ever picture is Rudy Giuliani
bang and Hillary Clinton I mean just
imagine that with his [__] that look
at his face when he was screaming about
the cops and then Hillary when she you
know [__] does that smile where eyes
get all wide all right I'm ruin your
[__] day picture her bent over with
the [__] eyes all wide neck
crazy smile and in behind the guy just
[__] banging away there you go
that's on your [__] hard drive down
you can never erase that oh [__] look at
me it just visit another one for the MMP
[__] Photoshop right there I'll look
for that one too
tomorrow on [__] now I guess today
you listening to it tomorrow for me on
the old [__] Twitter Twittersphere I
had such a great time this week you know
not having to go in the [__] writers
room has been awesome getting caught up
in all the [__] you know around the
house and all that type of stuff it's
just it's just a [__] only being a
comedian is the greatest [__] job
it's the greatest [__] job you could
ever [__] have just go onstage act
like a [__] idiot
and then afterwards hang out with a
bunch of comics and then you go home
then you wait 24 hours do it all over
get apologize for the yawn and all of a
sudden you know I don't know this is
something about listening to you to my
voice it just puts me to sleep
that's how I go to sleep every night you
know that I just start talking out loud
you know I'm saying it in the rain just
st. 20 minutes later I'm asleep anyway
so Monday night as I mentioned last week
I did I was going to be doing the
goddamn Comedy Jam and I busted out the
old [__] John Bonham getup and for
the first time ever I played my Ludwig
71 green Sparkle [__] kit had my drum
teacher swung by the house he tuned the
[__] things up so he sounded great
I'm like I don't know how they're going
to sound in the room the [__]
two-year anniversary of Josh Anna Myers
show the goddamn Comedy Jam which has
now become a [__] pilot on Comedy
Central the show is just blowing up so
happy for all those guys they had it at
the Roxy down on Sunset Strip now you
got to understand I am a I came of age
in the [__] 80s meaning I didn't get
laid till the 90s haha
anyway yeah the hotel was a rough one
for me right but basically the [__]
just a band that were going on that was
you know the Sunset Strip was total the
[__] hair metal you know the
beginning of the metal was [__] Randy
Rhoads you know when he joined Ozzy and
all those [__] guys and then it went
into the hair metal and then Guns and
Roses pulled it out in the end and then
[__] uh okay warrant and all those
guys all of that [__] happened on the
Sunset Strip out here and [__] in LA and
I used to always read about the whiskey
the Roxy the Rainbow Room you know back
when I used to read hit [__] Pereda
anybody used to read hit Parader
magazine I [__] love that magazine
you know they used to put all the curse
words in there and everything I would
you know what I would actually buy one
of those off a [__] eBay just to read
it just to see I'll remember that about
all of those [__] bands
I knew everybody's name I knew the names
of every [__] drummer I used to watch
all the videos you swatch the
headbangers ball Randi Rahman I used to
watch the top ten countdown that was
hilarious it was either like Janet
Jackson or some hair metal I think Janet
Jackson was was was like [__] [__]
music but these guys were wearing
lipstick and had the hair all pieced up
like some desperate soccer mom trying to
fall in the last dick of her life I
thought that that was [__] guy music
you know Britney Fox I've always brought
that up the girls school all that [__]
you know poison every rose has its thorn
all of that [__] right I got into all I
was into all of that then I started
working in a warehouse and I worked with
these [__] burnouts that were now at
burnout so they smoked weed but my world
that meant you will [__] burn out
back then you know cuz its back then
that was considered was bad if you
smoked weed it was illegal we didn't
realize that yeah it actually helped
with your [__] memory back then we
thought that that your memory it helps
with Alzheimer's whatever the [__]
they're claiming who knows you know the
whole [__] weed thing is it's it's
like the
global warming battle I just think it's
going to go back and forth and back and
forth and then eventually booze bags
like myself will finally give and be
like I write I write you guys were right
about the weak kind of weight people all
the corporation's finally went like you
know what yeah global warming is
happening in it is because of us but a
now it's too late
so I started working with these guys and
they played in a band and like I came
from more of a jock town right everybody
just [__] played sports or you just
you know I don't know stood in the
corner on a [__] wall during a party
you know it was basically yet those are
the only two options of town I was in
and these kids were from a couple towns
over and everybody over that played
played instruments and these guys came I
worked with him there playing guitar and
playing the [__] that was on the radio
and I didn't I didn't do all my agent
Lee he could [__] get that good
that's amazing and that's right then
when I bought my first drum kit abroad I
was 20 years old when I started playing
[__] drums I've done everything late
in life I was always [__] I had day
late and a [__] dollar short right
and I had this I bought a five-piece
slingerland kit at the time it was I
bought it in 1988 I think and it was
like ten years old it was all bottom
sizes but it was more like the 5-ply
once it wasn't the three ply shell so it
was they were already starting to
[__] make them too heavy but it was
black and it had got a k-member the
[__] sizes it was hopefully it had an
18 inch floor tom a 24 inch kick and
then what the [__] was the rack I think
it was like a 13 it was really weird
sizes and then later I ended up I went
down to El Drew's shop in Woonsocket
Rhode Island I believe that's where it
was and I found a 16 inch floor tom
which is [__] unbelievable that
matched my kit even the Badger said
Niles Chicago on Niles Illinois sorry
and you know there's no [__] eBay
back then I there's no way to track down
all of this [__] that people had lying
around the house
I just went into that place they had all
these old drums they happen to have that
and I [__] bought that thing I was
nine by thirteen ten by fourteen
thirteen fourteen and eighteen and a
twenty four kick so then I got the six
sixteen inch so now I had I had a six
piece kit which I thought was the [__]
then I got some roto toms put them on
the other side of the hi-hat because I
was watching Alex Van Halen because it
was all about having the biggest [__]
kit you could possibly have and then
Along Came Guns and Roses and a guy
named Steven Adler and he showed up a
little 4-piece kit right rack Tom floor
tom and his [__] ride sitting in
between the two which was just it was
the [__] and he got more music out of
that than half these [__] guys with
double bass drum kick [__] to toms
above each bass drama to floor toms
right and that just completely changed
my life so long story short I always
read up on all that I try to do all try
to figure out a spin the sticks all of
that [__] back in the day all I could do
is watch MTV
and try to figure the [__] out or you
just listen to the records and we had it
even better than the kids in the
seventies because there was no [__]
MTV maybe he caught him on I don't know
dick clark's [__] show with some [__]
so but all used to ever hear about was
you know if you wanted to [__] make
it in rock music back then you had to be
down there so here we are [__] almost
Jesus Christ 30 years later I finally
get the [__] and go down there on a
Monday night and I got to play drums at
the rock scene which was [__]
incredible
and I sucked when we practiced like on
Thursday I sucked on Sunday and then
during sound check
I was only okay I was like god dammit I
had all these friends coming down I go
when she [__] Nokia hadn't played and
played since March and I'm a comedian so
I already sucked even when I was playing
and so I went out did my set dressed his
[__] bottom and I sat down behind the
kit I don't know what happened I just
took it and I'll just kind of laugh [__]
it right and I ended up playing for me I
played great I had the most fun
I was the Lucius that I've ever been and
was [__] hilarious I'm playing the
song and Dave Kushner
who does the music for f is for family
and also was in Velvet Revolver he was
playing the song - he always you know
[__] around and [__] makes me laugh so
I had this stupid fake moustache glued
to my upper lip and he was making me
laugh and I knew I couldn't smile it was
going to come off so then half of it was
[__] flap and he started laughing and
then that they literally floated off my
face and we're only halfway through the
first song and then I had this stupid
bandana around the [__] John Bonham
wig that thing came off then the hair
was in my face I look like the chick
from the ring and my sunglasses started
fogging up so it's funny I was I was on
a green sparkle kit dressed as John
Bonham when we were playing ac/dc none
of it made sense so of course it was you
know working that because you know we
just [__] around so then we did
Highway to Hell and in the end that was
the Encore we did Highway to Hell and
then everybody we bringing everybody out
Bert Kreischer to [__] destroy he
opened he did a Red Hot Chili Peppers
give it away now and not only did he
come out just wearing the sock he talked
to everybody in the band into doing that
I was not out there for that and then
Margaret showing up she [__] killed
it
Harlan Williams saying eyes without a
face he [__] killed it and then Ron
White went up and saying Leonard Skynyrd
give me three steps
I hope somebody took some video of this
[__] so I had to follow all of that and
fortunately that was a great crowd and
so anyway so in the end they brought
everybody out to sing Highway to Hell
and they kept me on drums by then my
hairs that wig is in the face I can't
see through the [__] sunglasses and
in the end they just wanted me to keep
doing like the cymbal wash thing as they
introduced everybody you know another
round of applause for everybody and I
forgot and I couldn't see so I kind of
stopped playing I kept hearing the
guitars it was a [__] but it was
hilarious and I want to thank everybody
that came out and I have to tell you
that's the best sounding [__] drum
kit I've ever played in my life
26 inch bass drum
the way my teacher tuned it up and the
way they miked it up it sounded [__]
unbelievable what I loved was everyone
in the band was saying how great the
[__] kids sounded and I don't know I
have to figure out I swear to God
I have to figure out a place where I can
just set that [__] thing up that's
the oh that's what sucks about having a
[__] there's no place to play when
you play drums you have a [__] guitar
you can turn down your amp there's no
way to do it and you know as fun as
those electronic kits are I don't just
talking drums on this but who gives a
[__] I barely ever talk this much about
drums they got these drums like if you
live in an apartment right the way it go
if you still want to play is you buy a
set of v-drums
alright those are the best electronic
drums as far as I'm concerned that are
out there you buy that mid level one so
it's not that much money there's always
one used on eBay and then what I used to
do was I would put foam down on the
floor then just build the little two by
fours and some plywood just build a
little drum riser okay put carpet on
that foam and another layer of carpet
okay and then you put the drums on top
of that and then what you do is you go
downstairs and you meet your neighbor
you tell them hey I play drums I'll only
play during this is what I used to I say
I'm stand-up I work nights all right
I'll play during the day only Monday
through Friday if I'm going to play I
play during the day if whatever reason
if you're ever home during those times
here's my phone number just call this
number and I will immediately stop I
mean that's that's the best you could
[__] do I told this story before then
the guy end up being a [__] you know one
time out of the 5,000 times I played he
ended up being homesick or some [__] or
he had a vacation and he called up
alright I pick up the phone I'm like
hello and he just goes can you knock it
off like right out of the [__] gate
and I was like alright Jesus claims I
was younger then now would have been
like dude hey yeah you [__] say that
like you said it to me 50 [__] times
you [__]
I gave you my number
couldn't be any nicer all right I'm
going to stop let's go [__] yourself
please call me again if I bug in I would
have laughed at them and I would have
left it at that
but anyways three alley is you're not
playing drums if you're on an electronic
kick I can't explain it it's weird
because if you're playing electric
guitar you're really playing guitar but
there's just something about those
electronic drums I don't know I think I
I think most drummers would agree with
me there's something you play you sit
down on electronic drums and you're like
how have I not [__] toured the world
is one of the greatest drummers of all
time this sounds I sound incredible on
this [__] thing and then what happens
is then you sit down find a real kit and
you actually have to make the sound
happen rather than just [__] hitting
somewhere on the pad and getting a nice
snare sound or [__] bass drum then
also to get on a real kit you're like oh
that's right that's right I'm not one of
the greatest drummers of all time it's
the exact opposite I'm one of the worst
[__] drummers that ever [__] lived
this is an embarrassment I should be on
electronic kit because at least those
you can turn down so anyways I can't
stop thinking how [__] unbelievable
those [__] drum sounded I'll do they
sounded so [__] good in between we
played if you want blood and then when
they'll bring in everybody out like I
was just I still had to keep playing
them they sounded so [__] good plays
with that beginning beats in my time of
dying back bad to go like okay they just
found it he sounded [__] amazing
thoughts killing me I swear to God I
swear to God why the [__] that I build a
gym out of my well because I don't want
to be a fat [__] lovely hilarious if I
built a drum room instead and I put
those things out there nobody get here
and then I didn't work out I got fat and
I started looking ever see those awful
pictures of John Bonham when he had the
[__] wife beater on Jesus Christ dude
he's like 27 years old back then like
people just looked so [__] old I
don't know what I don't know what was
going on back in the day you know like
they just showed that [__] lunatic
that [__] lunatic
john hinckley who shot Ronald Reagan
shot Brady in the head totally altered
that guy's life quality of life scan oh
he's [__] people he shot they just
let that guy out and oh by the way he
was obsessed with Jodie Foster because
he kept watching her and taxi and yeah I
think she was like 13 years old and that
[__] thing yeah let's let that guy up
that that's a good thing to do
jesus [__] christ the guy's been in
it for 35 [__] years what's he going
to do you're going to go you're go
working on those yogurt shops I mean
what exactly is the guy has no [__]
resume you know you can imagine that
guy's [__] resume what it must be life
just be like I keep mr. Hinkley let's
see here and he was 25 when he got
arrested 1980-81 let's see so let's just
say let's say he was a go-getter he got
his first job at 16 so he would add nine
years on his resume that takes us back
to about about 1972 let's see 1972 he
had a job stocking shelves in a grocery
store II did that for a couple years and
he got a job at a bowling alley it's
gonna be all 70 [__] right and then you
shot the president all right and then
there's a yeah what's that 35-year gap
okay shot the president 1981 and now you
uh you want to work here at staples say
what we're going to put this in the bin
I'm going to have a manager look at it I
want to thank you for coming in and no
no there's no reason to contact us well
we'll get back to you as soon as we can
I don't understand that is why I think
they should do they should [__]
transfer it Hinkley to wherever the [__]
John Charlie Manson is all right
you stick them in side-by-side cells and
then they just host a reality show you
don't neither one of them has seen the
outside world for roughly the same time
whatever Charlie Manson's got like 10 12
years on it but at that point you up to
35 [__] years you know I've been in
for 47 you said that doesn't [__]
make a difference all right you
you just haven't just [__] talk
locally locally now just have them talk
about just you know random [__] you just
show them a video give a little glimpse
of the outside world
hey yeah Charlie Manson why do you think
about Lady Gaga's meat dress you know
whatever the [__] going on in the
world I had on all right that's a bad
idea Joe is that a good reality show
we've taken some of the most infamous
criminals of the past 50 years stuck
them all in a circle of cells and your
eyes won't believe what happens next you
know it's funny as I could probably get
to at least the second level of pitching
that show strong interest before the
whole thing fell apart and they realized
like a wave and how the [__] are we
going to get transfer this guy to the
other prison the overheads too high you
know all right
there's always a moment with every
podcast where it goes off the [__]
rails and I'm going to go out on a limb
and say it's this moment right here this
is the moment right now where I wonder
what the [__] am I going to talk about
next do that guy 60 [__] years old
now
he spent from 25 to 60 years old in a
[__] nuthouse and they're gonna they
gonna let him out now what [__] job
tree is a six-year-old yeah you got any
odd computer skills you sit now what are
those you mean those giant things from
the Six Million Dollar Man now they're
like biggie they weigh like [__]
three pounds now you know he probably
thinks it's a plastic book
I don't know what they said they're
going to [__] try to monitor this guy
what the [__] is wrong with I just I
don't understand it I don't understand
the egg and there's nothing - if you're
gonna [__] give a guy 35 [__]
years just put him out of his [__]
misery right Wow what would you rather
do would you rather spend 30 years in a
35 years 25 to 60 no one at 60 you get
now or they can give you the old right
there Fred you know your choice I think
I choose a firing squad fire to go out
[__] get electrocuted you know or
have you put me down like some old
collie a little [__] injection I
don't want that [__] who would want that
I don't just [__] have me in front of
a firing squad right hey do it's not the
face just [__] center mass boom done
over all right there we go can I mention
I can't remember cause I started this
podcast a couple of times here did I
mention I got some new dates coming up
okay I've mentioned the European dates I
got some new dates coming up that are
going on sale this Friday and I'm very
excited about this because these are the
shows these are the shows that I'm doing
is I'm getting ready to do my fifth
hour-long stand-up special very proud of
that my five you five special
anniversary okay here we go I got to
make update coming up coming up hey it's
coming up this is in Huntington New York
at the Paramount Theatre
Wednesday September 7th is at 7:00 p.m.
and a 10:00 p.m. show this is the make
up show for that show that I cancelled
due to weather out on Long Island
earlier this year back in January I
believe finally making that one up and
then on September 8th I'm in at the
Charleston Galliard Center in Charleston
South Carolina
September 10th I'm in Norfolk Virginia
at Chrysler Hall September 11th Sunday
Richmond and Richard in Virginia at the
Altria theater and then let's see the
next weekend I'm swimming with great
white sharks I'll tell you about that
later well gee just getting over a fear
is stupid Thursday September 29th I'm in
Madison Wisconsin at the Orpheum Theatre
October 1st holy [__] [__] does that say
Omaha Nebraska it's just going to be my
triumphant return - no I have not been
in Nebraska since since I was always
doing college gigs I don't I can't
remember the last time I was there the
Orpheum Theatre okay that's going down
on October 1st all right this is when
we're getting down to crunch time we're
getting closer to the special Thursday
October 6th I'm in Atlanta Georgia at
the Fox Theatre Friday October 7th I'm
in Gainesville Florida all right what
the [__] what a goddamn Yankee like me
be doing down in Gainesville Florida on
Friday October 7th well I'll tell you
what boy out of anyone that's because on
October 8th the LSU Tigers are playing
the Florida Gators down there on the
swamp I cannot [__] wait to go to
that game I love both those programs and
I've always been a dream of mine as a
sports fan to always to go into that
Stadium before they tear it down and
give them some new flashy new one that
[__] looks like everybody else's I
just want to see the lay up like that
whole section of that weird wall where
it just says to swamp like what the was
that one those multi-purpose stadiums
that they used to be able to spin it
around and to make it a baseball diamond
and then after a while it just broke and
they said [__] it it's a football field
I have no idea but I want to go see that
very unique looking stadium and their
fans are [__] awesome and as its SEC
football and then from Saturday October
15 2/3 a October 20th I'm going to be in
Washington DC at the National Theater
now what's great about that is uh I'll
be doing probably a couple shows a night
oh it's a theater
maybe I'll just be doing one a night I
don't know what are we doing but I'm
that's the crunch time I'm working every
single to Saturday Sunday Monday Tuesday
Wednesday Thursday
doing a little residency I believe what
they call before I get ready to do my
special and I never write my [__] down
and this time is a few things that I
think I'm actually going to try writing
out and then improving on it and just
seeing how it goes on this special just
to try something different you know I'm
always trying to do something a little
different Kippy giving you the same old
bill every [__] special right so I'm
very excited about that I'm ridiculously
excited about the European tour coming
up not excited about the long flight and
you know the lovely Nia will not be
going with me to those [__] shows I'm
just doing because it's a thrash I mean
it's all right for me because I get to
be at the higher doing the show but
she's just going to be getting [__]
hey you like this city alright here's
another one you know every [__] day I
think that would get a little old but uh
so anywho I think that's it right is
that my little half-hour I do my little
[__] penance for the week here huh
seven seconds underneath thank you to
everybody
once again they came out to the goddamn
Comedy Jam and thank you to Josh Anna
Meyers and all those guys for letting me
get to play at the Roxy dude dressed as
John Bonham plaintiff 71 Ludwick Ameen
[__] you know what I mean that's it's
that's some [__] someday when I'm
[__] old and I'm staring at the wall
still drinking of course I'm going out
like Peter O'Toole right still [__]
drinking I'm just going to have the
greatest smile on my face just thinking
about [__] like that like I [__] did
that that was so much [__] fun and uh
it was just great I will do that show as
long as we [__] do it and so that's
it and yeah that's it now I'm off to
Ireland next time I talk to you I don't
know when I'm gonna be I don't know
where I'm gonna leave me laddie I think
I'm going to be over and uh I think I've
already done the three dates in Ireland
maybe or maybe not I don't know all I
know is I think I Drive from
Bristol to Manchester England and if I
have time I have to pay my respects to
John Bonham's grave and I have to do it
I'm going to do it no [__] selfie
none of that [__] you know try to do
in the classy [__] wedding you know
to me I always remember because I went
to Elvis's house one time I just felt
bad I wanted to actually laugh like I'll
get a bit out of this and I went to his
house Graceland I just felt bad I just
felt like I was intruding on the guy's
personal life and after they had like a
gift shop across the street with like
Elvis cuckoo clocks like that guy is one
of the most exploited [__]
entertainers of all [__] time the
guy's been dead for almost 40 years
they're still making money off his
[__] image thinly and you walk by his
grave in the back it's just like a bunch
of people just walking by and yammering
and saying dumb [__] and they're just
the sound of [__] flip-flops and
poverty just walking by it was just bad
yes it's like what what are we doing
here what are we doing in there like an
Elvis had three TVs because we used to
like to watch all the [__] games and
the TVs are all [__] out of date but
you know something when I went in there
into his house
I really saw how [__] like yeah this
must have been the only place that this
guy could go to escape how famous he was
and he must have been really nice for
him to be here and just be able to chill
and relax and it's just really [__]
ironic that this place that was so
peaceful for him is now we're all tricks
and through it all trying to stretch our
heads and look up the [__] the
upstairs so maybe you can see the toilet
that he [__] collapsed from you know
it's really bad alright I guess I'm
going to end on that alright and I I
commend anybody who really honestly sits
there and watches these Republican and
Democratic national conventions at this
point you can actually sit through there
I didn't watch it but did did the
[__] guy there Bernie Sanders did he
did he just completely flip-flop and
endorsed Hillary is that what he did I
mean just how could I do something I
just don't understand it hi
sit there watching somebody in a debate
trashing somebody and trashing them and
trash from trash and saying why they
think they're going to be awful and then
when the person they say is going to be
awful beats them they then just do a
[__] 180 you'd be like I think this
person that I said sucked is going to
make a great president and as my full
endorsement
so anyways all right that's it I'm done
Yap and that's it I'm not gonna lie to
you I'm still [__] buzzing off that
[__] show Monday night I still can't
believe I got to [__] do that so cool
so [__] cool that's it alright go
[__] yourselves have a great weekend you
[__] and I'll talk to you on Monday
[Music]
all right [__] up I got a couple of
reads I got to do here I didn't see him
all right Club Kevin Daniel challenge
innovated concept I'm going to pick this
copy here have you ever been in the wine
aisle at your local store just staring
at the massive selection of wine with no
idea which bottle of booze to choose
from most of us go with the bottle that
has the best-looking label and hope that
it's going to be good well the days of
playing Russian roulette with your wine
selections are over because the club
tell you looking out for the terrorists
is a revolutionary new wine club that
takes the class the guesswork sorry out
of choosing your wine they have a simple
sixth question palette quiz that will
match you with delicious high quality
wine you are guaranteed to love the best
part is that at Club Debbie Ann plans
with Dick Cheney will actually ship your
wine straight to your door no more going
to this door and being lost in the wine
aisle love wine we've got the perfect
wine for you at Club Division Club
debbie is a revolutionary wine club that
delivers high quality wine straight to
your door they partner with the
innovative wine makers from all other
all over the world to produce a wide
variety of small lot handcrafted wines
for their members with Club Delia
sit down try to kill my dad let's go
here Rommels which is mass destruction
you have the freedom to pick up and
choose the types of wine and the number
of bottles you receive
once the best part is they offer a 100%
satisfaction guarantee on every single
bottle bottle start drinking
personalized line selection today try
Club W I'm going to dance don't care if
it's a funeral
alright that's it now where the [__] do
people go to get this is there anything
here I don't know 20 dollars okay right
go right now God Club W is offering
listeners $20 off your first order when
you go to club Debbi a.com slash / and
it gets even better I know you hate
playing for shipping and all that [__]
so act so Club Debbie yeah well I'm
gonna bash my intern aquifer will
actually pay for your shipping on orders
of four bottles and more so take
something off your to-do list join club
w comm slash burr to get $20 off your
first order now that's club Vivian calm
/ burr alright last one no let me just
stop here alright what is it about
buying a mattress that leaves you
feeling violated is it too pushy people
the fake Presidents Day sale or the fact
that you know you regret what you bought
as soon as you want you do the walk of
shame on the mattress store those days
are over
thanks a helix sleep where you can buy a
mattress online customized for you for
hundreds of dollars instead of thousands
thousands of [__] pays $1,000 for a
mattress geez some high-quality [__]
right there go to helix calm first
answer a few simple questions and helix
Korea Alex creates your custom sleep
profile to build you the perfect
mattress the result our customers report
30 percent improvement in their overall
quality sleep your mattress will arrive
at your door in a well to week ship it
is hundred percent free you have 100
nights to try it out if you don't love
it they'll pick it up for free grow and
give you a hundred percent refund no
questions asked
it's like it never happened yeah Jesus
if you do love the new hellix mattress
keep it and your dignity that's why
everyone from GQ magazine to Forbes are
talking about HELOCs sleep go to helix
sleep calm slash bar and get $50 off you
order that
like sweet calm / / hey helix weak calm
/ / watching her they closed and I was
doing for my hand was holding her she
was great burton Iowa
the scope did I stay bouncing around the
room
[Music]
hey what's going on this is bill burr
the Monday morning podcast and this is
the third attempt at trying to be even
remotely amusing on this thing because
I've been on vacation last week and too
happy and I'm too relaxed at a great
time down and tuck it one of the one of
the whitest places on the planet
not that was funny I just literally had
to pause when I said one of the what his
things because someone's color was
coming by and for some reason I thought
that it was going to be viewed as racist
like I was actually going like yeah it
was really white it was awesome it was
actually it was so white I believe my
level of whiteness was actually
offensive if you can believe it and yeah
very I can't explain the welfare it's I
don't know I was staying out ensconce it
which is even more snooty than nonentity
but uh if you ever get out there
his little tip will give you take a trip
of the [__] brewery out there to hell
the name of it Cisco Cisco Brewers and
make their own beer wine and vodka out
there and go on their website if you're
a big vodka drinker cisco.com I believe
but just look up Cisco Brewers CIS Co
I'm telling you this [__] is smoother
than great news it's it's unbelievable I
guess the island sits on an aquifer the
amount of times people told me that in
the last week it's just some point it
would come up you know this island sits
on an aquifer and like you I was like
what the [__] is an aquifer except I was
on vacation so the [__] was there was
more like oh and what might an aquifer
be evidently you know I don't know what
it is I was going to go on the internet
I was going to look it up but as far as
I could tell from the drunk people and
their boat shoes and their tigerwood
shorts they were saying that
nantucket was formed from a glacier and
somehow I know it fits on fresh water
and the water trickles under all kinds
of bedrock and [__] from Massachusetts
and [__] that just really killed the
cleanness of the water hey [__]
coastal Massachusetts and [__] it's like
really [__] clear but it yeah it goes
right underneath the ocean and I guess
it comes right up and that's how they
make their vodka tastes so good I
learned that trick it all my life and I
had no idea that the cleaner the water
is smoother and more pure your your
heart stuff is so maybe that's why all
those hillbilly's and make a moonshine
up in the Appalachian Trail you know did
they talk to somebody not ten people I
know who've walked the Appalachian Trail
somehow got Lyme disease and you know
I'm all up for an adventure but when you
get like a disease that they did an
episode about on Little House on the
Prairie
you know I mean basically some
18-hundred [__]
you don't mean you get AIDS I'll look
the other way I mean we've all put the
gun to a head you know I'm saying that's
a modern disease but you get like
typhoid fever for the plague I say
what's [__] up man I was reading this
book on the population and I think I
talked about this I can't I can't
remember
lesyk I was doing podcast so I'm a
bathroom in this cabin I was saying that
cause it's the only place I could get
some sort of cell phone service but uh
reading this book about population and
basically I think medicine medicines
would really [__] us over a lot of
people think it's dumb people [__]
and creating more people that's really
caused the population problem but it
isn't it's smart people giving dumb
people tennis Ilyn that has got the
population explosion and I can't stress
to you enough having traveled as much as
I had truly how many people need to die
in an avalanche for us to ever save the
polar bears
I know what the [__] I'm talking about
got a goddamn sunburn on my brain here
alright if you're new to my page man I
got a big thing coming up here I was
saying last week my special was coming
out on August 23rd they just moved the
date I had my own one-hour stand of
special coming out on Comedy Central on
August 31st alright and it's called what
do I do this and it's actually coming on
after one of Dan Pope's specials which
is great because he has like 9 million
fans so if a third of them hang around
it's going to be a great thing for me
yeah August 31st and this week my CD
comes out will be in stores of the same
name it's basically a CD of the special
that's coming out on 31st and in
September the DVD will be coming up so
look for all that in stores I'll have
more information this week and I'll be
putting something up on my website as
far as uh to give you all that
information but let's get down to the
podcast questions because my flights
going to be leaving here soon my flight
to Charlotte and then on to LA I don't
know why I got the connecting flight
seemed like a good idea stupid all right
bill with all the latest postings what's
obstructed my laptop justice what are
you doing cut it out hang on you know
that when you try to click on something
then it selects it and then just starts
going 90 miles an hour down the page all
right bill with all this posting of late
of spontaneous crowd members heckles and
interruptions it's getting me wonder
about wondering about a couple of things
alright I thought you're reading that
question that basically fame in the last
month I put a couple of postings on
YouTube and on my myspace page people
yelling out random [__] during my shows
her question is you seem or his question
I don't know who sent this you seem to
be pretty nice generally to these people
even if they're being a dick but I'm
sure that's always that's not always the
case
have you ever offended someone to the
point is I'm trying to fight you or made
someone cry or something else really
awkward actually you know what the two
people heckling me the lady going thank
you and the guy who's in the crowd who
was blind neither neither one of them
will
malicious which is why I wasn't being
malicious back to them you know what I
mean that's kind of how I work it if
someone's being a dick to me I become a
nuclear dick to them because you have to
out the exam you don't say where'd you
get them you got a ten times meaner than
they're ever going to go
you don't mean it's like that
Untouchables they bring a nice you bring
a gun you know they make fun of your
[__] head you talk about their
mother's vagina cancer or something I
know it's disgusting right
but idea I don't make the rules that's
how it works all right you want to
change the stand-up world you go do the
Late Show you go do the third show
Saturday night and the middle of [__]
nowhere and you tell me that vaginal
cancer does not seem like a viable means
of self-defense I'm not wishing that on
anybody but I'm not above bringing it up
and wishing it on a crowd number I don't
know and it's hypothetical mother all
right it was brutal anyway so you ever
offended someone to the point of them
trying to fight you
yeah I had one girl chased me around the
stage one time and I didn't know what to
do you know because she was broad and if
I hit her I'm going to go to jail which
is a funny thing about that you know I
mean it's like they're getting up there
and they got a glass and they want to
smash it over your head you know I'm not
trying to be a dick but at the end of
the day that is you know the average
woman is weighs over 100 pounds
you know upwards of 150 you know the
average broad out there you know they
got some DEET it ease they might be
pushing 160 who knows right you start
swinging a glass you know I never took
physics class but you can really [__]
somebody up for some reason because they
have a vagina cancer free of course all
of a sudden now I have to stand there
it's really there's really no way to get
out of it without looking like a tool
either stand there and you let some
girls smash you over the head be you run
away and you look like the biggest [__]
ever or see you blast them in the face
and you know then you look like you know
you look like a wife beater rather than
know there was another adult with a
rational brain who's you
had a glass which is considered a sin
attempted murder if you smash I know if
you smash up a bottle over somebody said
that's assault with a deadly weapon I do
know that as is if you bump into
somebody with your car
I learned that another one I'll tell you
that story here in a minute basically
what happens is lady came out on stage
so I don't know what the [__] to do so I
just picked up the mic span and I put it
between her and myself sort of alligator
armed it didn't have an extended way out
because I would seem too hostile so I
kind of had it you know I didn't have it
up against me because I would defeat the
purpose so I kind of had half way you
know so it's like I was extending an
olive branch in a way and I basically
backed up in a circle and she was so
drunk she kept following me until lacy I
think she got tired it was Dangerfield
where it happened and of course there's
no security there so they probably just
sitting there laughing in their Ocean's
eleven boys cloak waist-length redcoats
last bucket why am I even trying to be
funny here I'm too fun to relax I'll be
funny next week
Gary forgot the story that I told you I
was going to tell you Jesus Christ let
me go back here a second with the
[__] I was talking about being on
stage somebody chasing you all the car
think oh that's right
what I was in a car right and that was
driving that unbelievable yeah I know
I'm living an amazing life driving down
the street and I put on my left
directional to get into the left lane so
there's this lady in the left lane but
there's enough room for me to get in but
she does the kunti thing she stomps on
the gas right so you know trying not to
let me in you know I mean and drives you
know she basically cut me off she
doesn't let me until I get behind her
I'd be better so she beats at me so I'm
like what the [__] I'm right you cut me
off I beat back at her and then she just
snapped she just slammed on the horn and
held it all the way up to this red light
which is like a football field away she
just went like like a half a mile
staring at me I could see her beady eye
staring at me in the rearview mirror
came all the way up to the red light my
hand and ii she stopped I just beat real
quick I went beep get the pisser off
just so I get it laughs you know the
next thing you know I just see her
reverse lights come on and she [__]
she backed into the front of my car
really lightly I'm like what the [__] is
this girl doing and then I see her
reaching into the glove box and I was
like oh my god she's got a gun and there
was somebody behind me so I couldn't get
out and I'm glad I panicked I didn't
know what to do so she jumps out of the
car and you know I rolled down my window
like a crack and I'm so scared right you
know this is this psycho lady I'm like
what's your problem she ended up having
a pad and a piece of paper and she wrote
down my license plate number then she
jumped in the car and she drove away
unfortunately somebody saw it and they
said hey was that a friend of yours
because that's how lately she hit me I
said no that was some psycho and the
person gave me their business card which
I kept so because I'm a [__] [__]
I just completely forgot about it and
next thing you know I'm on the road and
all of a sudden I get a phone call yes
hello this is officer Shepherd calling
from the El Segundo Police Department
investigating a hit-and-run possible
assault with a deadly weapon
basically what she did was she backed a
car into my car and then said I
rear-ended her but I had the business
card so I was able to get out of it and
you know who knows I don't know what
would happen you know I could have gone
to jail and someone would try to rape me
and then I'd have to kill and then I'd
be like Tom Selleck in that really bad
movie you know
that's why I like Shawshank Redemption
that's the only one with a dude actually
they show what would happen if an
accountant goes to jail you know he
doesn't start winning weights and
somehow take over the jail now you know
what happens he gets [__] raped and
it gets raped for years and that's why
you always want to have a [__] alibi
okay especially if you have in a bad
marriage to go into a tough time
whenever you go out always make sure you
get a friend with you okay because if
you don't someday when someone does you
the favor of a wagon that [__] chick
that you sickos are they're going to
blame it on you and then you know what
you're going to get raped repeatedly um
unless you're good at math you know and
the wardens a piece of [__] and you're
shining shoes or ever the [__] that
plays out I don't know I don't know look
all I know is this I get a special
coming out August 31st called why do I
do this please do me a favor tell as
many people as you know any people you
don't know just bug people just tell
them to watch it
August 31st my CDs coming out this week
August 30 stores Comedy Central and then
my DVD comes out in September I don't
know why it's happening like this but
that's the way it's happening so please
watch that and then come up see me
because I've already written a whole new
wall with this cuz I'm a [__] yeah
that's what another [__] you know who
kept oh I'm [__] I'm on my way to be
in the [__] trying to be the [__]
alright that's why we're not that's the
real reason or I wrote another hour
actually that's not the real reason the
real reason why I wrote is because I'm
so [__] paranoid once my material has
been out there dad you know that's a big
nightmare of my being on stage telling a
joke and having the whole crowd going
you already do doing TV what the [__]
and then I just start bombing and then
somehow it spreads across the internet
no one ever goes to my shows again I got
to move back in with my parents
then again I'm working in a warehouse
again I'm loading trucks you know what I
mean
catastrophizing I believe is the thought
process
okay I'm gonna wrap this thing up I'm
going to be at a the comedy works these
are the gigs in August and we get the
comedy works
in Denver Colorado uh starting this
Thursday I think that's July 31st
through Saturday night August 2nd and I
go to my website Gilbert calm to get all
the information I'll be at the Miami
improv somewhere around August 12 I
don't know the [__] dates in front of
me that they sit right there in the
MySpace page you can see and then after
that I believe I'm doing I'm doing the
stress factory in New Jersey New Jersey
so I get the hiccups now I'm trying to
think if I can remember any more podcast
questions somebody asked me a great
question I didn't copy it but it was
copy and pasted where I can read it
right now what the [__] was it had
something to do what is the most
overrated thing you ever saw in your
life and what do you think is the most
underrated and that's that's too big a
topic just come up with one answer I'm
going to answer even more of it next
week but the [__] off the top of my head
that I could say was the most overrated
[__] of all time uh let's see Josh
Hartnett The Strokes
Tony manda rich any old sports fans out
there member that guy the incredible
bulk sky was an offensive line they put
him on the cover of Sports Illustrated I
don't know what they thought he was
going to [__] do but he didn't do it
what else was overrated Fame not not
being famous just that TV show Fame
everybody seems to love that show Bruce
Springsteen I don't get it I don't
[__] get it you know the guy sells
out Giants Stadium 19 times in a row so
it's got to be me but I'll tell you I
don't I don't get it I I don't I don't
[__] get it so I guess it's not
underrated
that would be what how about is a good
years ago much you guys once you guys
answer me this one what's the most
popular thing that everybody was into it
say you didn't get okay yeah I'm not I'm
not trash and Bruce Springsteen like
he's [__] you know in sync or a
boyband
you don't mean I'm talking about like
like you know those [__] plastic
see-through clogs that everybody seems
to be wearing now
Crocs you know I don't get it
any person to wear shoes like that is
stuck in mario batali
okay and I'll let you can make pasta
through the well method you shouldn't be
wearing those socket thanks okay I
didn't care if you're on Hell's Kitchen
is the worst [__] show on TV if you
can't believe the way those people sit
there and they let that guy yell at them
bad enough you got to go yes chef
you don't I'm saying like you won a war
or something [__] guy makes tuna
tartare get over yourself I ever had a
child he just allowed themselves to be
yelled at by a [__] chef to that
level that guy looks like an in shape
Bobby Kelly I know Bobby Kelly's losing
weight you guys should go and courage
him by the way he looked great last time
I saw these I'm looking at the after
picture of Bobby Kelly Walker bonfire
that he will get to because I have faith
in them what else this [__] I talking
about
oh yeah this shift that everybody's into
that up that I just I just don't I don't
get you know okay something that's
really [__] underrated water water is
really underrated water is one of the
most underrated things of all time
there's no reason for coke soda these
[__] sports drinks the electrolytes
and all that [__] way they did just
drink some water I'll tail it up it's
underrated if you eat a banana and apple
and an orange and then later on day you
just have a house salad you will be as
regular as a [__] racehorse how these
stupid shows on commercials but they've
given people tales and we stuck in old
people you know follow them working
anymore it's like if they would just eat
some fruit you know any eat some fruit
and then have a [__] salad and I'm
telling you Moon River any flesh fans up
um what else what else is [__] okay
you know what okay so one thing that
ever left lived up to the hype was the
iPod the iPod is one of the few things
here I'm saying that ever lived up to
the hype
and speaking of hype I'm going to seat
Batman this week and as far as I know
Heath Ledger lives up to the hype
playing playing the Joker
okay it was [__] up somebody had the
amount of people who came up to me with
theories as to why he old because people
thought he killed himself rather than he
sort of took the wrong stuff the wrong
time you know what I mean wrong amount
you know somebody told me he goes you
know what you know what I know why I
know why I don't know why I know I
killed himself he was he was losing his
hair can you [__] believe that it was
one of the dumbest feelings like he
couldn't affair looks like he couldn't
he couldn't afford [__] hair plugs
I'll get one of those John Travolta wigs
you don't know saying would you shave
your [__] head take a nod from me you
don't I mean wow how would you kill
yourself just get it you know I just I
don't I don't buy that
the guy didn't kill himself he just
unfortunately I don't know what happened
I was like I'm going to try to act like
I'm Trapper John MD here you know which
I'm not obviously haven't even played a
doctor on TV and I know I haven't I like
I like how it only took me eight seconds
to run mentally through my whole [__]
acting career so anyways what time is it
here
oh all right my planes going to be born
here in a few minutes once again thanks
to everybody who came onto my shows in
Pittsburgh please everybody watch my
special on August 31st called why do I
do this on Comedy Central my CD comes
out this week I believe on August 4th or
5th try to find that in stores and you
guys really seem to be liking these
random videos that I've been making
different kind of tape in every set that
I do and if if I basically is what what
I'm going to do is if if I I just go off
on a risk that's kind of specific to
that city or if I have a good
back-and-forth with somebody it's a
great way to give you guys some new
laughs without me having to burn any
material you know I'm saying no you know
what I'm saying all right that's it you
guys all have a good week thanks listen
my podcast and I'm working on a new
website and I will be putting all of my
blogs up there okay that's why I haven't
blogged in a while I have been blogging
but I have not posted any of them
because evidently the Facebook's the
MySpace and the French stirs they own
anything you post up there they own like
I can still make a book of my blogs
which is what I'd like to do but so can
they and you know I don't like working
for free I don't know about you guys but
I don't like doing that so you know I'm
just going to start the whale blog on
myspace from here on out is I will just
put something you know hey I wrote a
blog and then I'll just put a link to my
website that's how I'm going to do it
because yeah you don't say I'm blogging
blogging for me
I'm blogging to make you guys laugh I'm
not blogging to get [__] Rupert
Murdoch's a more free content alright
and that is it you guys all have a good
week and I will talk to you later please
go out and buy my CD in stores this week
I believe it's August 4 I really wish I
had a date I don't [__] know August
4th August just look forward why do I do
this in stores tell me what you think
and keep those podcast questions coming
and let me know let me know some of the
shipping you think is overrated all you
think is underrated and the one thing
that I don't know people are just
totally [__] into when you're not
which might be the same thing as saying
something is overrated I don't know
there you go why don't you send me the
definition of overrated - all right how
does a week like
siren sang a song for me the difficulty
as I think I see this through a crystal
head
[Music]
you know freestyle bounced around
whenever a big cold day - Chris plays
yeah about the problem
I think old babe
[Music]
for a tower full moon
and
stop
y'know
[Music]
totally
Oh
[Music]
ah
[Applause]